so there is a fantastic new company
called skip lagged and of course they
are being sued by the big boys Orbitz
and United and why are they being sued
let's take a look
so what Skip black does is they find
cheap one-way fares by surfacing weird
airline pricing strategies like pricing
in New York to San Francisco Lake Tahoe
flight cheaper than in New York to San
Francisco flight so you booked all the
way through to Tahoe debark
at San Francisco and walk away from the
final leg okay so this is pretty great
we've done a bunch of stories on these
new types of companies that are doing
things a little bit differently away
from the big boys like Tesla Airbnb uber
things that people love and then of
course the lobbyists and the big
companies sue them and fight with them
and all that stuff so this is pretty
great and it was done by a 22 year old
kid he created this thing he's now being
sued for $75,000 let's take a look at
the lawsuit so in the lawsuit United in
Orbitz called skip leg unfair
competition and alleged that it's
promoting strictly prohibited travel
they want to recoup seventy five
thousand and lost revenue okay so the
the seventy five thousand is nothing but
this is just the worst of the worst this
is somebody figuring out something cool
I mean it's exactly what's happening
with uber and Tesla and and Airbnb in
all these cities somebody figuring out a
way around the system to help the
marketplace help the common person what
happens the big boys come in yeah
give me something make me feel Wolff I
want to I want to change my vote and
make this guy the most admired Man of
the Year he's my hero
that you might fly every firefighters or
Ebola dogs or whatever no no yeah this
guy is my hero for taking down the
airlines and I love that you know their
idea you know what we got to do we got a
quell that's got a quash it you know
before it gets too big so we'll sue him
and then there'll be news stories about
it everywhere they'll be talking about
it on the internet and we're gonna I
mean his site is down now because you
can't keep up with all the traffic so
genius I mean right okay so let's just
talk about the lawsuit for a second
because that's that's the stupidest part
so let's just get it out of the way as a
former lawyer so 75 grand they're suing
him for nothing just to scare him right
that's just a scarin but it but in
actuality they're doing exactly what I'm
saying what I hadn't heard about this
until they lose someone for unfair
competition that's just a basically
catch-all phrase yeah just say like I
don't like what you're doing I'm gonna
sue you for there's no specific cause
I'm just going to sue you right and
unfair competition is very broad so you
can't get thrown out a court so it could
go to trial and the problem was going to
try that costs a ton of money there's no
there's no way this kid can possibly
afford going to trial fighting this and
winning yeah he's literally a 22 year
old did this in his apartment in New
York but also I look I'm not a lawyer
obviously between it to say unfair
competition he's not he's not creating a
business that's competing with them he's
just creating sort of a way around how
dare you inform our customers about
different pricing strategies that is
outrageous right and but I know I've
always wondered about this because you
would you would book a flight you're
looking for a flight from New York San
Francisco and you can't and then you you
look at another flight that you go into
LA and it goes through San Francisco but
the LA flight is cheaper like what the
hell is going on here and the airlines I
don't know why they are so you know they
want to continue with this sort of a
pricing strategy because I guess they're
the idea is we're gonna try it the ideal
situation is you have a full flight
where no two people pay the same amount
that's like the you know the harmonic
convergence for an airline but and if
they have want to come out and explain
to the American public why it's to our
benefit that nobody can know why the
where the prices come from and how they
come or arrive at them I'd like to make
that argument in court so is that what
this is really about that the airlines
want to keep us all in this constant
state of having no idea what a price is
ever supposed to be or how the book or
how they arrived at or anything I just
booked a flight for for April from LA to
New York and I think I got a pretty
decent price but I just kept thinking
well why should I wait longer do I you
know like what's the there is no rhyme
or reason to it right problem the
problem is that airline prices are too
cheap okay and it's too cheap in the
sense that airlines can't make any money
they're losing money all the time so so
the good thing is that they're
affordable so most people can afford to
travel right air maybe not
internationally but domestically they
can't the downside is that if shitty
service
and the workers get paid crap yeah and I
need to make sacrifices constantly and
one of the ways de the airline's make
more money is to couch people for
first-class tickets who can't afford to
pay it and to have these weird
mysterious pricing structures but
they're not even that weird or
mysterious because it's really Southwest
Southwest that's the price whatever
price they're at right all other
airlines follow it and maybe hike it up
by two dollars or they do tricky things
like yeah we're not gonna you know it's
cheaper than Southwest however we're
gonna charge you for for bringing
anything on the airplane or charging you
whatever for for drinks and a massive
change fee fit to change anything so
there's all these little games they play
to to make money and they actually make
money on those fees without those fees
there'll be massive in the red so that's
that's part of the problem and what this
kid has done is try to he lifted that
layer so you can see underneath it and
see what's really happening it can make
informed choices and the airline's they
don't want you to make informed choices
because that means you save money and
pay less which means they even they lose
even more money yeah their margins are
very tight obviously which and the the
fact that they you know if you need to
go somewhere this week and you have to
book that late then they're gonna
they're gonna gouge you and doesn't even
do about it because they all do it so is
that why no airline has ever come out
with a flat rate thing you know that
they're just flat rate to these cities
no matter what because I would love that
idea like even if sometimes you're
paying a little bit more just the idea
you don't have to deal with all the
nonsense like Saturn pricing strategy
it's like instead of or buses right if
you want take a bus from here to Las
Vegas it's the same price yeah I mean
it's posted you don't have to do a
search for that particular day it's just
posted right so do we need we need an
Airbnb or uber of Airlines right like is
that the only way to ever sort of fix
this or get it to a more sensible rate I
don't know who's gonna be flying these
things a lot of people there aren't as
many airplane owners as car owners I
suppose yeah but some I want my air
travel to be regulated and safe all
right
what do you guys think I like the idea
you're at the airport and you're like is
this my plan is this humming what do you
think - what can we do to get airline
prices down subscribe a comment down
below